suck so anyways I finally got a meeting
with Bellamy the bacon bits King now I
know my campaigns awesome the problem is
everybody I talk to says Bellamy's a
real ball break that's what they say
yeah well Nik you're my brother and
you're incredibly successful yes I am I
was hoping that maybe you could give me
some tips that might give me an edge
when I meet with them okay sure here's a
good one when you greet him give him a
good firm handshake and don't release
until he does no no no no I want
something different something special
wear a red tie
power time that's bush league I'm
talking about a secret weapon your neck
Oh secret weapon huh okay I think I know
what you're after if I tell you you got
to promise not to tell anybody else I
promise that's just sort of a long-term
strategy when's your meeting with
Bellamy week from today not much time
but it might work
yeah okay sure every time a penny passes
through your hands stick it up your ass
what and then spend it thanks Nick yeah
I thought you were really gonna help me
how does sticking pennies up my ass give
me an edge when I meet with you don't
just stick him up your ass you spend
them and like I said it's a long-term
strategy I've been doing this for 11
years now every day for the past 11
years I've stuck 30 dollars in pennies
up my ass I use them for everything cab
rides movie theater groceries what does
that accomplice --an it's a lot of
Aspen's I got out there my friend and
here's where the magic comes in when I
meet with someone who intimidates me who
puts me on edge a real hard-ass I just
think to myself they've probably handled
one of my ass pennies in fact they
probably have one in their pocket right
then that just seems to sort of give me
the upper hand
I mean hey I haven't touched anything
it's been in their ass
hey where's billing me like to eat he
likes to eat at the pump room great
here's what you do go to the bank today
get yourself 50 dollars in pennies stick
them all up your ass one at a time of
course they go to the pump room buy
yourself a nice dinner paying entirely
in pennies now they'll be using your
pennies for the next week at least
Bellamy goes in there to eat he gets
your ass pennies for change by the time
you meet with him you know he said
something in his hand that you've had in
your ass so so then you get the upper
hand no I don't yeah you do it's just
like imagining someone in their
underwear no it's not
it's horrible yeah well it works for me
you know what I used to look up to you I
used to think you really had it together
oh I do have it together little brother
you don't pull down eight figures a year
without having it together you don't
have it together Nick you stick pennies
up your ass for confidence that's not
having it
gather do you think you're better than
me I didn't say that oh you didn't have
to it's written all over your face you
have any change in your pocket why take
it out why go on take it out and take a
good look at it
oh my you've got a few pennies in there
don't you
I've been sticking $30 in pennies up my
ass for the past 11 years that's three
thousand pennies a day
twenty-one thousand pennies a week 1
million ninety-two thousand pennies a
year to date that's 12 million twelve
thousand pennies eight times the
population of Nebraska those pennies
were in my ass you think you're better
than me oh you're not better than me you
handle my ass pennies every day you pick
up my ass pennies for good luck you
throw my ass pennies and fountains and
make wishes on them you give my ass
finished your little daughter to buy
gumballs you handle my ass pennies every
day all of you you all handle my ass
pennies I laugh at you before you can
laugh at me because your pennies have
been in my ass